depuis six mois j'ai sillonné les
territoires fragilisés par la crise
à la demande du premier ministre et du
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance pour essayer de formuler
des propositions pour le rebond
économique des territoires me suis rendu
dans les 13 régions de france
métropolitaine dans 15 départements
une cinquantaine de communes à la
rencontre de plus de 650 interlocuteurs
sur le terrain quel est l'impact
territorial de la crise eh bien il a une
dimension territoriale forte beaucoup de
différences entre les territoires qui ne
se résume pas d'ailleurs aux différences
de spécialisation industrielle entre ces
territoires et qui se reflète dans le
ressenti des français que nous avons été
captées sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis un effet inattendu sur les
dynamiques et les équilibres
territoriaux avec une absence de
recouvrement entre la géographie de la
baisse d'activité pendant la crise et
celle des fragilités antérieures à la
crise autrement dit la carte de la crise
économique ne recouvre pas la carte des
gilets jaunes les grandes métropoles
sont les grandes perdantes de la crise
la baisse d'activité il a été plus
marqué et on voit sa mort c'est un exode
urbain en provenance du coeur de ces
grandes métropoles et à destination des
départements périphériques un peu plus
ruraux un peu moins dense ce qui va
éviter le décrochage territoriales c'est
évidemment les mesures de soutien et de
relance
nous avons cumulé les montants des
mesures de soutien et de relance que
nous avons rapporté au nombre
d'habitants de chaque département
ça représente 2400 euros par habitant et
ça à cibler en priorité les départements
qui en avaient le plus besoin c'est à
dire ceux où la baisse d'activité a été
la plus marquée alors face à cela
quelles sont nos recommandations
ce que nous disons c'est que les
solutions viendront de notre territoire
parce que la tri crise les a frappés de
manière différenciée et parce que les
crises la crise les a poussés à
reprendre leur destin en main tout au
long de mes déplacements dans les
régions
j'ai senti sur le terrain un vent de
renaissance se lever et donc il
appartient à l'état bien sûr
d'accompagner cet élan est de permettre
au territoire de reprendre leur destin
en main pour le rebond en sortie de
crise
la stratégie c'est coopérer
territorialisée régénérer coopérer c'est
faire fructifier les capital relationnel
le capital territoriales qui s'est
développée entre tous les acteurs
économiques locaux en facilitant le prêt
de main d'oeuvre en modernisant l'usagé
des fonds de revitalisation et en
permettant aux entreprises de répondre
de manière groupée aux appels à projets
de france relance territorialisée ces
données aux territoires des leviers
d'action puissant et adaptée à la
situation qu'ils connaissent avec une
déconcentration plus forte de
l'instruction et de la publication des
résultats des appels à projets avec
l'attitude plus grandes données aux
préfets de région dans l' usage des
crédits dont ils disposent pour pouvoir
intervenir en fonction de la situation
différencier des territoires et puis
c'est une accompagnement renforcé du
soutien à ce qu'on appelle l'ingénierie
avec la proposition de créer un site de
rencontre entre l'offre et la demande
d'ingénierie qui s'appellerait
ingénierie point gouv.fr et avec l'envoi
sur le terrain des hauts fonctionnaires
qui viendront en appui aux collectivités
pendant cette période
le troisième pilier du triptyque c'est
donc régénérer régénérer c'est soutenir
la création de nouvelles entreprises le
développement des jeunes entreprises en
leur donnant le plus de facilités
possibles et on crée en capital jaune
pour permettre à la jeunesse et bien
d'entreprendre de créer de reprendre des
entreprises au moment du rebond
économique
c'est évidemment revitaliser les sites
industriels en déprises c'est faciliter
la conversion des bureaux en logements
et puis c'est faciliter les
restructurations d'entreprises là où
c'est nécessaire et faciliter la
formation et la reconversion des
salariés pour l'avenir
ce que je propose c'est de tirer les
enseignements de ce que nous avons fait
depuis trois ans et singulièrement
depuis le début de cette crise d'unifier
de concentrer les moyens à chaque fois
qu'un territoire sera en risque de
décrochage est ce que nous proposons
c'est un pack rebonds un pack rebond
c'est une boîte à outils anti décrochage
qui s'ouvrira tous les six ans pour que
les territoires les plus vulnérables
dispose de tous les moyens pour éviter
le décrochage industriels pourquoi est
ce que c'est important bien parce que
depuis des décennies nous avons eu une a
qu'une attitude trop passive par rapport
au déclin industriel et qu'il y a dans
notre pays des territoires qui ont
décroché
nous devons nous prémunir contre ce
risque à l'avenir en adoptant une
attitude beaucoup plus active beaucoup
plus contractuels beaucoup plus
ascendante beaucoup plus
responsabilisante pour les acteurs
économiques locaux et c'est tout l'objet
de ce pack rebonds